think about today if you're saying  something that's true but the government  calls it a conspiracy theory you can  lose uh if you're someone like me you  can lose your income you can be taken  off of patreon you can be taken off of  Twitter Facebook YouTube where did you  get taken off any of those I got taken  off of patreon yeah patreon took you off  what was their reason uh it's comp well  I wrote an article about the  affiliations of the creator of the  AstraZeneca covet vaccine and that he  was Affiliated in speaking to the Galton  Institute which was until 1989 the  British Eugenics society and some of the  affiliations of that particular  organization uh so anyway they didn't  like that